luffy is going to have the most
ridiculously large and powerful army at
the end of one piece we all expect that
this epic series will have one of the
most epic and intense final battles we
have seen in all of anime a chirag the
author of one piece himself has
mentioned more than once that he's
working heatedly on a war that will make
the battle of marineford look like a
playground's gruff between a few third
graders and so assuming that luffy will
actually have to call all his allies for
help is not so much speculation as a
promise by oda sensei himself and so i
think it's time to take a closer look at
all the allies that luffy has gathered
over the years that will fight this
all-deciding final war side by side with
him against the full power of the world
government the gorosei and emu a war to
liberate the world from a tyrannical and
exploitative rule that has lasted for
over 800 years because as you will
realize at the end of this video this
host is so large and so powerful that it
really raises the question of what the
government has up their sleeve to even
come close to competing with it at the
core of this army of all armies stands
of course the straw hat crew itself
under the command of the future pirate
king monkey d luffy a fitting title for
a commander that will lead such a
massive host the straw hats have already
pretty much established themselves as a
true yonko crew at this point anyways
the top fighters namely luffy zorro
sanji jinbei and most likely yamato are
powerful enough to take on pretty much
any opponent on the grand line at this
point and even the weakest members like
uso nami or robin have reached a
terrifying level of power in battle as a
crew with unwavering belief and a wide
variety of devil fruit abilities and
other useful skills the straw hats will
lead the final fleet into battle as the
flagship now the first massive addition
to the strawhead army is of course the
straw hat grand fleet that was
established during the aftermath of the
dressrosar an absolutely unimaginable
host of 5
640 men consisting of seven pirate crews
that were enslaved or imprisoned by the
donkey koat family in one way or another
we're talking giants long arms the
tantada cavendish's crew and of course
my man bartholomew while the grand fleet
will add an impressive number to the
main army i think it's important to
remember that many of its members are
top tier fighters that fought in the
colosseo many of them have haki or devil
fruit powers and especially the new
giant warrior pirates under the lead of
hyrule gene will have a massive impact
on the battlefield overall the other
major force that luffy will be able to
count on is of course the ninja pirate
mink samurai alliance that was formed in
front of the road ponoglyph on zoho i
personally think that this force will be
even more important and power packed
than the grand fleets the samurai and
ninja wano are known as probably the
most powerful people in the entire new
world with fighters strong enough to
oppose the world government for
centuries not only do most of them have
advanced hockey in the form of ryo but
the country is full of special ability
users including the likes of onimaru
tama or momo who has the same mythical
devil fruit as kaido himself then there
are of course the two pirate crews
involved in this as well that have
already fought side by side with luffy
in a battle to the death lost hard
pirates and the kid pirates despite
their pride and brawls with luffy have
been established as allies and true
believers in luffy that will stand by
his side against a larger evil be it
kaido or the world government itself
where the other supernova will join the
fray as well we'll have to wait and see
about that but many of them do seem like
likely candidates extract has already
fought with luffy hawkins
is dead bonnie who's connected to kuma
and has infiltrated marijuana i could
see many of them standing side by side
with luffy at the end of the series as
well the minks of course aren't far off
in terms of their fighting power here as
well i mean they have basically been
surviving and defending their home
against powerful invaders for centuries
as well and especially under the full
moon become one of the most fearsome and
most powerful weapons that you could
ever wish for oh and speaking of their
home country zunisha the gigantis
elephant that zou is located on is of
course gonna be part of this all as well
no matter if it's an actual ancient
weapon or just a monstrous walking tank
of destruction zonisha is gonna have to
play a central role in the final battle
that most likely will be tied to its
past relationship with joy boy in some
way or form as well i think and uh
speaking of the ancient weapons another
race that owns its freedom to the straw
hats now are shirahoshi and the fishman
now that i think about it actually i
guess technically fishman island is
actually still luffy's territory if i'm
not mistaken anyways with the fishman we
once again have a race of powerful
fighters that has been suppressed and
discriminated against for hundreds of
years not only are they able to fight
underwater manipulate the sea currents
and attack ships from below but their
princess the ancient weapon poseidon is
literally able to control the sea kings
mysterious giant sea monsters similar to
sunisha whose powers are pretty much
forces of nature at this point i think
two pretty clear patterns emerge luffy's
most terrifying ability as mihawk calls
it to bring people to his side fight for
him and believe in him can be divided
into two categories i think on the one
hand you have people who have been
liberated
and saved by luffy this is true for
pretty much all of the straw hats in
some way or form robin from anas lobby
sanji from whole cake island jimbei from
impel down but of course also for entire
islands including the fishman whom he
saved from hodie jones and their
internal dispute about their racial
identity guano from kaido's tyrannical
rule or law from his obsession with
doflamingo and his lifelong quest to
avenge corazon luffy saving people and
bringing them out of their darkness no
matter who they are and what they've
done has always been one of his most
powerful character traits my personal
favorite example here is probably
katakuri whom luffy saved from his
isolation amongst his own crew and the
pressure that he felt to never be
himself and show any weakness category
by the way also someone i really expect
to stand side by side with luffy at the
end and then on the other hand there are
also many people that luffy has brought
to his side simply by earning their
respect and inspiring them to entrust
their hopes and dreams into him a great
example here for example would be
whitebeard luffy did not manage to save
either whitebeard nor his brother ace
during the ward marine fort but his
actions and will earned him the yonko's
respect and as a result luffy has the
powerful remnants of the whitebeard
pirates on his side as well including
marco and ezo both of whom fought with
him on wano in the same way luffy has
inspired mihawk to help zorro and very
possibly help the crew again in the
future and even though there is of
course more to it it is also the reason
why shanks and rayleigh and possibly
other former members of the roger
pirates will be fighting by his side as
well i mean hell even kit falls into
this category as well when you think
about it as i discussed in his character
analysis video it was luffy's
stubbornness and his willingness to die
and fight for him without any second
thoughts really that ultimately made kit
trust him fully as a comrade and now
wants to kill him whoops
another really big ally for luffy in the
final battle will of course also be his
father dragon and the revolutionary army
as a whole the revolutionaries are
already dangerous enough as an
organization that dragon has been named
the most wanted man in the world not
only do they have agents all across the
globe and most likely inside the world
government ranks as well but they also
have real heavy hitters in their ranks
as well including the commanders of
course luffy's brother sabo ivankov and
the entirety of the kamabaka kingdom as
well and we're not even talking about
the possible intel that dragon might
have about the true history and the
secrets of the world governments if
we're being honest the revolutionaries
might end up being one of the most
crucial pieces for luffy's success and
the downfall of the gorosei and emo but
even more than that there are also
forces within the marines themselves
that seem likely to side with luffy
sooner or later characters like smoker
or fujitora who have opposed luffy but
ended up respecting and cheering for him
as they witnessed his kindness and more
importantly the incompetence and
corruption of the government to keep its
own citizens safe from harm there are
characters like kobe who not only have
been one of luffy's closest friends
since the very beginning of the show but
just like x-drake is part of a secret
marine organization sword that is
opposed to the world noble's cruelty and
is fighting for a more just and also
independent version of the marines and
of course we shouldn't forget kuzan who
has been friendly towards luffy and the
straw hats right from the start and who
has been off doing his own mysterious
thing for quite a while now i think
you'd probably agree that he seems like
the type of character who would side
with the straw hats in their fight for a
justin free world as well which would
add one of the most powerful characters
in the entire story to luffy's ranks
someone who has control over the ocean
itself would be a more than valuable
asset in the final war luffy's
grandfather garb is of course another
clear-cut character here he will not
watch another one of his grandkids dying
he will fight on luffy's side in the
next big war and there are even more
potential allies that might join the
fight the warriors of skypia another
ancient race associated with the ancient
kingdom might come to luffy's 8. the
giants of elbaf another big arc that is
coming up soon will surely also end up
as allies to the crew similarly soldiers
from kingdoms like drum island with
dalton and kureha dressrosa with king
riku and rebecca and alabaster with vv
should join the battle with a number of
forces as well and as speaking of
dressrosa luffy liberated the country
from the rule of the donkey shot family
which includes this weirdly thin but
very slimy treble and it has been my
mission for a while now to overtake this
bounty of 99 million berries with 100
berries per subscriber we still have
almost 40 million berries to go so
please help me overtake this man by
subscribing to the channel then there's
also more of the warlords boy hancock
will be fighting for luffy just as
surely as zoro will many of the impul
down prisoners that luffy helped break
out including crocodile maybe buggy and
hopefully the one and only mr 2 kuma who
has been part of the revolutionaries and
has helped the crew before and who knows
maybe vagapunk will actually turn out to
be an ally as well as many people have
speculated before adding incredible
technical knowledge and prowess to the
mix as well and others like sanji's
family the windsmokes and their germa
army should be on the straw head side as
well at this point i think and the
biggest wild card of them all is most
likely gonna be shanks and the red hair
pirates however should they actually
survive and turn out to be actual good
guys after all having them join luffy's
grand fleet would instantly increase
their power multiple times i mean
seriously getting another yonko crew
would just really turn this into the
ultimate force to wage the largest war
the world has ever seen so i want you to
really close your eyes for a second and
imagine this army with entire nations
the most powerful fighters on the ocean
ancient weapons and invincible devil
fruits all united under the straw head
banner all of this of course leaves us
with one really big and really important
question what sort of terrifying secret
power please does the world government
and emu have up their sleeve to counter
this sort of army to make it more or
less a fair fight the next arc on the
way to this major battle is going to be
elbaf and if you want to know what might
happen on the island of the giants you
really shouldn't ignore this video right
here